From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
We're ready, John.
We're rolling.
I'm Emilye Crosby of the Southern Oral History Program at the University of North Carolina at Chapel Hill.
And I'm conducting this oral history as part of the Civil Rights History Project, which is sponsored by the Smithsonian Institution's African American,
or sorry, National Museum of African American History and Culture and the American Folklife Center of the Library of Congress.
Today is August 24th, 2013, and we're in the Northborough, Massachusetts Free Library, and I'm here with Mrs. Virginia Sims, George, her husband, Frederick George, and John Bishop, whose videotaping.
I'm doing the videography.
Thank you for joining us.
I was wondering if you could tell me about your family and where you're from and growing up.
I'm actually from Virginia, and when I say that everybody, you know, quickly say, oh, you're named after the state, but my grandmother was named Virginia, and my father indicated I was named after my grandmother.
Who probably was named after the state?
But I was one in Newport News, Virginia, which is on a tidewater, and I have one brother, who's 13 months older than I am, and my father and mother separated when I was a very young child, and so I was raised by my father, my brother and I, for the most part.
So I went to school in Newport News, I'll just share when I was coming up, Newport News was very mistakenly.
And I grew up, and I just in town, and my father remarried, and after he remarried, he, they bought a home, and we moved out to the suburbs, and when we moved to the suburbs, what was happening was all the white people were leaving that area and going further out, where they would not be living with blacks.
There were two people, I think, still there, when we moved, and she was on next door neighbor, and she happened to say to my father that had I known, you know, that you guys were such good people, I never would have sold my home.
But that was my first, it really experienced with the idea that there was a difference. And then going up to visit my aunt, who still lived on the street where I was born and grew up, I actually took a bus, which was the first time I'd ever ridden a bus in town.
And I was probably about 12, I didn't know really the etiquette of the bus that I got on, and there's a seat, you know, like this way and then the rest of the seats go, and I sat there, and there was a white lady next to me, and I wasn't sure, I didn't know, I shouldn't have sat next to her, she jumped up, she moved to the other side, and she started to look at me, scrambling and frowning, and I felt so bad, and I remember going home, talking to my father,
and that's when my father talked to me a little bit about rage and the experiences, and in his mind, the thing to make a difference was education. And my father would always say, you know, you need to get your education, because if you get it up here, no one can take it from you.
That was one of the first things, and my brother had lived in Germany for about five years, and he came home, and he and my father went to a hardware store, and a white clerk came up and said, what can I do for you boys?
And I think my brother having lived in Germany for such a long period of time, you know, realized that really wasn't white, and I remember him telling us that, he said, you know, this is my father, he's no boy, and he left.
But in Virginia, where I grew, they used the words boys and girls as a means of demeaning like people.
So I had decided that I wanted to be a lawyer, and I was going to, you know, fight for the civil rights of all African-American people.
I graduated from high school, and we didn't have counselors, you know, that really gave the kind of advice that our children get today.
So I ended up going to Virginia Union University, and actually my father had gone there for a year, and I think the dorm that I stayed in used to be a man's dorm, and it really had turned into a woman's dorm.
So I went there with not really thinking I was going to be a lawyer, and majoring in history.
And it was straight history, because the intent was to go to law school somewhere somehow.
So that's a little bit about me.
Can I ask if you follow? Sure. Questions? So what kind of work did your father do?
I followed with the postman.
And so you said that when you, when he remarried and bought the house and moved out to the more suburban area, so was this in the 50s?
Yes, yes, yes. And that's when, and this is when there's that sort of transition with white smooth out.
Right, and moving out and blacks moving out to their area.
So the neighbor lived there long enough to get a sense of your family, but had already sold her house.
Had already sold her house, and it was too late to turn around, you know, but she was saying, if I'd known, I wouldn't have.
That's a really kind of thing.
Yeah, that she would, nothing, it would be true, but just that she would have that thought and articulated in that area.
Never will forget that, you know, because the neighborhood that we moved in was, as I said, was transitioning.
There were a couple of doctors, African American doctors, business people and everything like that.
All, you know, to the white people, it was like they're black. You know, we can't mingle, can't live together.
And so they sold their homes and they left.
Really considered the class issues at all.
Or, yeah.
Or that we were people.
Right.
You know, and that probably nice people as we turned out, you know, to be, but, you know, my father was a postman, he was very active in organizations and very much encouraged us to go.
And get educated.
So at this point in Virginia, well, let me actually back up.
So do you remember things like the Brown decision or the little rock integration or anything?
Yeah, yeah.
So it all on TV, you know, and it was interesting and something that just, you know, never thought about, you know, because so our schools were black.
We had our neighborhoods, RIP Black. When I was a little kid, there was a store.
I remember Jefferson Avenue was a busy street. And on that store, there was a department store run by white people.
And that's where we would go and we would shop.
But we had our own, you know, like restaurants or places to go.
It was totally separated. So you didn't really come in contact with white people of my father being a postman worked on a route that was white.
And so, and he enjoyed it.
He'd come home Christmas with these big bags of presents because all the, you know, post all the people really loved and respected him.
And they remembered him at Christmas.
But, yeah, it was done that time, you know, we expected to go to a black school.
We had black teachers. We had no white teachers, you know. And everybody, the principal, the counselors, the teachers, everything was ever with black.
It's interesting, too, because Virginia at that time probably must have been while you were in school because of the timing.
You know, it was closing schools. The Prince Edward County Schools, I think, that were part of the Brown decision that when they were forced to integrate, you know, Virginia was the one with the states leading the way in closing black schools rather than, or closing public schools rather than integrate.
Now that only happened in a couple of communities.
That's what I was going to say. So, in our community, at the time, it was still, you know, so I was born in Newport News next stresses Hampton + Hampton + Warwick, and then you had Hampton + Warwick.
What started to happen was that Newport News, and it probably had something to do with voting and representation and everything like that.
They began to expand Newport News over to one work. So that probably was taken into consideration that a lot of white people had moved out of the town and they were in war.
And so then the boundaries were moved so that you could keep it, but, you know, it was a way of life for us.
So in Newport News, we're African Americans able to register and vote at that time.
Yeah, they were. We were.
Okay. So in some ways, it's a, you know, I know different states have different cultures and different parts of the state.
So the thing to also remember is Newport News had first-of-the-month shipyard/sailor influx ship building. So they had this Amongus business because they built these very, but three city blocks long ships and everything.
So you had, you know, that industry there plus you had Air Force, Army, Navy, merchant Marines, you name it.
First of the month, everybody these ships, these sailors and everybody would hit the town.
So needless to say, I didn't go out.
Okay.
I had to be, I had to be Shaffer Road.
And the worst Shaffer Road of all was my brother, you know, I couldn't go, I couldn't go out unless I went with my brother or with my neighbor and friend because her mother would take us to places and bring us back.
But so you had that happening in town at the same time.
I was going to say so there's in some ways there's this federal influence probably.
And there's a strong enough African American community to have a self-contained business.
Right. Right. And in our churches of course were like everything.
Fuehnerhomes, churches, drugstores because one of my first jobs or not my first but one of the jobs I had was I worked as a soda-jerk clerk in a drugstore.
And the person, one of the owners of the drugstore, son was my brother's best friend and lived in the block just ahead of us plus another doctor.
So Dr. Jones and Dr. Tucker owned the drugstore.
Okay.
And so of course all of us, blacks came to the same place again our prescriptions to have Sundays or by the things that we need it that they carried.
So it sounds like it must have been in many ways a good community to grow up in.
I think so. You know, I think you know sometimes I share a threat. I was a debitant and all like that because we had our own society and being a debitant meant that you didn't date or you had not dated and everything like that.
And you were selected to be presented.
I know it's foreign to people today but because I wasn't able to go out and to date I could not date until I was 16.
And when I was 16 I was presented to society where you had meetings, you had practice and everything and it was a debitant criterion where you wore white dress, gloves, pearls, Pearl Earrings, etc.
And you danced with your father.
Did you enjoy that?
I loved it. I remember actually my stepmother made my dress and it was so big.
My uncle, my dad wasn't driving at that time and so my uncle had a big, oh, Cadillac and I remember sitting in the back seat and my dress took the whole seat, you know, and everything like that.
So it was fun, you know. I think of it, you know, I did. I really feel that I had a lot of great experiences.
I had a lot of great people who influenced me and helped me.
One of my very best friends, I babysat for her. Her name was Mary and Benz and her husband was a first black urologist in Virginia.
And I used to babysat for her and she was also encouraging me to go to school and helped to get my wardrobe and helped me to save and everything like that and the same for the next door neighbor.
So I felt that I had a lot of support.
Wonderful. Are you okay?
Okay. You mentioned that incident on the bus and deciding that you wanted to be a lawyer where those connected. I mean, was it?
You know, I don't know. I just remember that incident had a real impact on me because, you know, I just got on the bus.
I hadn't done anything to her. I didn't even know who she was. Probably would never see her again, but it began to help me to understand that there was a difference in me because I was black and she was white.
And that's when you began to know that they're differences.
And I remember my father would come home and tell me about some of his people he cared male to.
Their daughters were getting married, you know, going to high school, getting married. And that was the thing that they did and he did not want me to do who that he wanted me to go to school because he wanted me to be better.
I wanted me to be better in my life, having an opportunity, I guess, to be better in my life.
So I couldn't say, I guess the other thing, there was a lawyer. Her name was Marion L. Poe. And she was the first African American female lawyer that I ever knew.
Or so. And I just thought she was marvelous and wonderful. And I wanted to be like a like attorney, Poe.
How did you see me? How did you know that church?
She was a church. And I just knew her from church. I went to school with her grandkids, probably.
Did you remember whether you and other children in the community or at church, whether there were discussions of the NAACP or the events like the Montgomery Pust Boy Codd or things like that?
No, I can't remember.
Yeah. And so when did what year did you start college?
1959.
1959. So you were there in fall 1959?
The fall 1959 was my first semester. What was that like?
There was a lot of fun. It was my first time away from home.
Yeah. And living on my own. And I remember I got in a little trouble because in Virginia,
it was a very, it was a Baptist school. And you just couldn't do things.
I remember when you wanted to go out, you were supposed to ask. And I remember and you swore to go with another student and everything.
And I remember going downtown to Richmond by myself without checking out without asking.
And I met Marie Sallason, who was one of the people who was arrested.
She's, you've seen her, may have seen her picture.
Marie Sallason and Patricia Washington, well the two of them were roommates and they were diagonally across the hall.
And we said they used to get in trouble and I would maybe ground it because of them, but we hung together and we had a lot of fun.
You know, doing crazy things like I remember one time Marie Sann, Patricia Washington were chasing each other around the dorm or something and the dorm matron
making too much noise and came in and grounded us.
Because I was sitting on a bed laughing.
Well, they were being bad and I was part of it because I was supporting them.
And they were supposed to be clean in the room because we were going away for one of the holidays or something.
And then they weren't getting it done and all like that.
But I really enjoyed the first year because the dorm had a basement and you could go down in the basement.
They'd have dances.
So even though if we were grounded, we sneak down there anyway.
You know, like take a, because it was the washed area as well.
So we take a blouse or something like we were going to wash clothes and go in a dance and then come back.
So we turned the clock back.
So that when we went, we ran before curfew.
So these are things Fred doesn't know of how we did.
We did a little devilish thing and I never told my father but I remember asking my father if I could go to the Penn Relays and he said yes.
And I didn't tell him how it was going and he didn't ask.
So we actually went in a car.
My reads Patricia Washington and I just went with some guy to Philadelphia to the Penn Relays.
Well Patricia Washington was from there, from outside of Philadelphia in a place called North Town.
And so we were all going to stay at Patricia Washington's house and we had an opportunity to meet her parents.
And it was really nice for a relationship as a matter of fact.
I think the next year I went to Philadelphia and I stayed with Patricia Washington and I worked during this summer before going back to school.
So when you all would go off, sneak off to the downtown Richmond without signing out.
Is that because you're going to do something that you couldn't sign out for just resisting those regulations?
Probably a little bit of both but one time we went down there so I have to tell you Patricia Washington could pass with white.
And None of us could understand — her parents looked white and her mother and father they really looked white and Patricia Washington looked white.
So we went to Richmond and I don't remember when this was, we went to Richmond and (Marie + Pat + Virginia in Richmond) Pat went into a white barbershop, a white barbershop.
We waited outside, she went in and got her hair cut.
And they didn't know she was black because she looked white.
She was doing that just because of the segregation and things like that.
We thought it was funny.
So we went with her and waited and she got her hair cut.
We came out and said oh they don't know.
Instead of means of resistance.
And Marie so Marie's Patricia Washington and I, we hung together and we did things together and consequently when they were talking about the sit-ins of three of us,
we didn't know band it together of course and we were going and all three of us got arrested.
Do you remember how you felt when you first heard or do you remember how you first heard about the sit-ins?
Well they were going all around.
I mean you had, I think it was in North Carolina with the Woolworth that you had heard about them.
And then people were actually coming to the campuses talking about getting involved.
Really Martin Luther King had come.
We had two people who were ministers, Frank Pinkston and Charles Sherrod.
I remember Shirley Miller Sherrod.
You remember her?
Okay.
But Charles, the two Charles and Frank sort of led, pulled us together.
And we started to talk about it, we had meetings, we started to talk about it and strategized what we would do in Richmond.
Can you describe Charles Sherrod and Frank Pinkston?
Oh it's been so long ago.
I remember Frank, I remember board glasses, he was a minister and it's very nice.
Both of them are very nice, very articulate and great leaders.
Great leaders.
So they were really the kind of driving force?
They were the driving force and they were the ones that helped us to understand that they probably would be taken.
Because it was obvious that they were our leaders and that one go down, the other one was standout.
So it wasn't a matter of us falling apart because the two of them had been arrested.
So they prepared you for what would happen?
They prepared us for what happened.
We had other people that were working with us and everything and they talked to us about the need for nonviolence, the need to become,
the need not to let people get to us because certainly there would be that happening to us.
And so and it did.
Were you afraid?
I was, I wasn't afraid.
I was so excited and I was so proud and the interesting thing is I never talked about it.
I mean, I don't even know when I finally told Fred, I might have told him Irlon and our relationship but I remember my young nephew coming and he was telling all his friends that Jenny had been arrested and all.
But I never, never ever talked about it.
It was just something that I had done because I felt it needed to be done because I just felt that black people were treated so unfairly.
So I was excited, you know, I was excited when I was shocked.
It was after I got out of jail and everything and that's a different story but I came home and I was looking at the night news and I saw myself.
I saw them lead me out of the store.
I remember them putting me in a Paddy (wagon), in a squad car to the, I guess, to the paddy wagon came and then beat me from there and put me into a paddy wagon and I said, oh my god, I better call my father.
He may see the news, okay.
And that's when I realized, you know, I had, I needed to connect.
Yeah. So it seemed more serious when you actually saw that.
It was real. It happened and it was documented that it had happened and I needed to let my dad know.
Yeah. I'm comfortable. Is it okay?
It's always wonderful.
Can you, were you arrested on the first sit and you participated in or did you participate?
That was their one or two before that?
It was one.
We walked, we marched.
Okay.
And we marched downtown and then we went back and we went to this department store called Thalhimers.
Thalhimers is very much like Macy's with our Macy's, you know.
And the interesting thing about that store was we could shop there, but that was it.
We could go there, we could spend our money.
If we wanted something to eat, we had to go to the basement and they had a stand.
No, it was orange, Julia stands where you could go.
That's what we had to do.
And we spent as much money as anyone else with wood and did spend.
But there was the Richmond, the Richmond, I always call it the Richmond, where we were not allowed.
Black folks couldn't go in there.
And so that was our target.
And so is that something you'd experienced?
I mean you'd been down there and used that store before?
Oh yeah, I've been to the store. I've been down to the counter.
The orange juice, the hot dog, the soda or something like that.
And then you asked the question, well, how money is in our money good?
You know, our money spends, we purchase, we support the store.
And yet we can't, you know, enjoy the Richmond room because of our color.
You know, and that's when we just said, you know, that's when those of us, you know, we thought about it today.
That can't be, not today.
We need to change.
Times need to change.
Were there students that tried to talk you out of it?
No, not at all.
The students, the faculty, nobody said anything, derogatory.
We just got a lot of support.
Did you, I know this was true of students at some schools, but did you worry about being put out of school?
No, not at all.
Yeah.
We had support, we had full support.
Can you describe the support?
Well, there was never, I never remember anyone talking to us about what we were talking about.
It was about what we did that it was wrong or that we shouldn't have done it.
We didn't have any sanctions.
We were able to go to school, continue to go to school.
We were very much sought after.
We went to churches at night to see people greeted us with support.
They had dinners, you know, programs, they introduced us.
It was just like you guys did a wonderful thing.
And we really value and think, you know, that you're very special.
Well, that's wonderful.
And we had lawyers that bailed us out of jail and would be with us in some of the meetings that we went to.
After that first sit in and you're arrested, did the sit-ins continue in Richmond or were things sort of on hold?
I can't remember.
I think I can't actually remember.
I know the next step was we were going to Mississippi.
We were going to have some buses and go into Mississippi.
I don't know how many students when I know that's my father put his foot down.
He says, no, you will not go.
You need to stay and you need to focus on getting your education.
I don't want you dead.
Did you fear it for my life?
And so, of course I listened.
Did you feel, did you want to go?
Oh, I was ready to go.
At that time, I think what it happened, if I had gone to Mississippi, I probably would have been either dead or still doing stuff.
And maybe, you know, I don't know, my life may have taken a different chair.
But it was, I stayed in school and I don't really remember Emily.
What happened, because at that time, we were busy.
We, all those of us who got arrested, because we had to go to court.
We had to meet with the lawyers.
We were going throughout the city.
So I don't even remember the other stuff that was going on.
I just remembered that when I got arrested, I had long fingernails and it had trouble fingerprinting me.
So I was arrested.
I was taken to jail.
And they were trying to fingerprint me.
And they had difficulty fingerprinting me.
And by the time they finished my lawyer was there to bail me out.
It was very tight.
I remember being very tired, you know, because it had been a long day.
And I remember that I had walked to the city, walked to the store.
We had walked and stood in line.
We had been pulled out, arrested.
We were, I just remember it was like dark after sex.
And I remember walking with my lawyer, who I don't remember, the name, anything now.
And a white man stood in front of me.
It was big and spit on me.
And said something and the lawyer just, you know, like, got it me out.
But at that time, I think I had lost all of my none ballad.
And I was ready to do battle, you know, because I guess I've always been a little militant.
And I was ready to take them on.
But I didn't.
We had to move on and we could not engage.
That was the thing that it was emphasized more than anything that we had to be peaceful.
We had to be respectful.
And that went a long ways.
Did you worry that you might have trouble doing that?
No.
I didn't worry.
Only at that one point.
Because I think part of it was I was by myself at that time, because we had gotten separated.
I didn't know what had happened to my friends or anyone.
I don't even remember anyone being with me, but the lawyer whom I did know.
But there were a group of people who volunteered their time and their services to help us.
And so we didn't spend nights at something like an angel.
Like I said, I never saw a sale.
So did you feel good when you went and sat in that place that you've been excluded from?
I never went.
Oh, you did.
But I worked there.
Oh, yeah.
When I graduated from college and I taught another friend of mine, who we were teachers, you know.
And we had student loans.
It was Christmas holidays and they were hiring people.
So we went down and we worked.
I remember I sold books.
I worked in a book to book.
And I don't ever remember going to the Richmond rule.
Yeah.
I never remember that.
I've even excluded you didn't want to be a part of it.
I didn't want to be a part of it.
I never even crossed my mind.
You know, it was like the store was desegregated.
That's what we wanted, you know.
And that's what we had gotten.
So as long as you had access, you didn't really care what you went or not.
You didn't really care.
I didn't make any difference, you know.
But the people who wanted to, which was important, who wanted to do that, had the opportunity to do that.
Do you remember whether they integrated before the Civil Rights Act?
I don't remember.
Yeah.
You know, so a lot of this, you know, after I graduated, I taught at Maggie L. Walker (canonical first Black female bank president); the canonical Maggie L. Walker HS named for her High School, which was right down the street from Virginia Union.
I did my student teaching there in history.
And then from doing my student teaching, I actually got hired.
And so I came out of school and I taught.
And I taught for, I think, three years.
And I realized that I was so inexperienced from life, not so much the teaching I could do.
But the students were taller than I am.
They were more whirlies than I was.
And everything like that, that I decided I needed to have more.
Because remember, I couldn't go out when I was a child.
So I went to school, came home, or went to something function of baseball, a game with my brother.
So I didn't have the experience, knew nothing.
Okay.
And that's when I decided I would go, I needed, I wanted to get a master's.
I wanted to become a guidance counselor to be able to help students and to be better.
And that's when I went to the University of Maryland to get my master's.
And while there, I got a fellowship, so I ended up staying at one but two years.
And I never went back to Richmond after that.
So when you called your father after he saw it on TV?
I don't think he had seen it yet.
But he probably was a gentleman.
And he was, my dad was just, he was the best.
And you know, he said, I remember, are you okay?
Yeah.
I said, yeah, Dan, I'm okay.
He says, as long as you're okay, that's fine.
You need me, you call me.
I must have felt good.
I felt good, you know.
But that's the way he was all the time, you know.
Was your brother in Germany?
I mean, in the service by then?
He was in the service by then.
So he was not there.
He wasn't there to keep you off of the streets.
Or either to get after me or say anything.
But, yeah.
You know, I know this happened at some schools,
but was there any protests or discussion ever
in your union about the restrictions on students at that time?
About signing out or anything like that?
We accepted it.
Yeah.
It was a small, black Baptist school.
So we had to go Sunday night, we had to go to BYPU or whatever that is.
You know, some kind of church services at night.
That was part of what we did, you know.
When we accepted that as a part of coming to school,
because those were the restrictions.
And if you didn't do it, it would affect your grades and things like that.
So to my knowledge, you know, we did our own way.
So we did our own way.
We did our own way.
We did it our own way.
There were ways of getting around stuff.
And I think we did, you know, without protesting everything.
You know, so.
Yeah.
One of the things I'm interested in, and I've been studying a little bit,
is with the sit-in movement, is the participation of men and women, you know.
And then, and I was wondering if you thought about that at all,
or if there were any discussions about, you know, whether it was safe for women.
No.
Or, you know, I should do this because no.
Don't remember any of that.
It was just, you know, it was a group of students who decided that this was something they wanted to do.
Yeah.
They didn't, we didn't think about gender.
We didn't think about grade or age at that time.
I think I just, I was 18 when I went to school.
I think I'd just turned 19 in December and incidents with February.
So we were, we were some of us were young, some of us, you know, just didn't know the city.
But I mean, you know, if we almost, we didn't know the impact that we had,
or that we would have.
So that came as a big surprise, you know, to me it was, hey, we wanted to,
to say a great Richmond, we wanted to stop having to sit in the back of the bus.
We wanted to be able to eat, to go where we wanted to go, do what we wanted to do.
And that was all that was important, you know.
We wanted Patricia Washington to be able to go get her haircut anywhere she wanted to go, you know.
And so that was all we were thinking.
Yeah.
You know.
The, nothing else mattered.
Yeah.
And did you have a pretty good idea before you were arrested?
Did you know the lawyers were going to support you and be there to get you out?
Oh yeah.
So you didn't have to worry about like staying in jail.
Didn't worry about, didn't worry about all we had to do with our tasks was to go down,
was to pick it and to try to desegregate that room.
That was our task.
Yeah.
And that's all we focused on.
And we had to support, you know, financially, everything.
Yeah.
And I don't know if you would know.
So this happened in, you know, February of 1960.
Yeah.
And I know in April is when Miss Ella Baker called a meeting of student leaders from the sit-ins.
And that was at (Easter 1960) Shaw University.
And Charles Sherrod was one of the people who went to that.
Did you, were you aware of that at the time?
Or was that sort of just a kind of separate?
Sort of thing.
And then I think, so I would say that what happened at Virginia Union was just one incident.
Yeah.
Just one incident was focused on that.
As I remember, but that's like 50 years ago.
I know.
Okay.
So the death of my memory, that's all we did.
We focused on, that was our task, that was what we wanted to do.
Those of us who participated at that point, some people probably went on and continued to do sit-ins at other places and everything like that.
But my father, we focused to me.
So after that, first was like, okay, you did, but you had to do it.
You did it.
You wanted to do that.
You did that now.
You get back into the swing of things and get your education.
Did you ever consider pursuing the law degree or did you decide you had another interest?
A number of times.
I remember, I think I finally just realized that it would never be.
I remembered that at one point I thought about taking the L.S.A.T.
This is an adult, as an adult, because once I got my, once I got my masters, I actually went to work for a private company.
And it was in Washington, D.C.
And it was an inner-city plant.
And my role was to try to get, it was black people trying to get them off the welfare roles, off drugs,
and out of jail.
So I was a counselor, and I had, whatever needed to be done, that's what I did.
So for years, I worked there, I want to say probably two years before moving to Minnesota.
So was this like the late 60s or the 70s?
The late 60s.
Yeah.
And did you enjoy that work?
I did.
Yeah.
I think part of, I always had to, I wanted, I always wanted to help people.
I wanted to see people survive and to do better.
So it was like, you know, getting someone out of jail, getting them on a path to learn and a trade was really a positive thing for me to do.
There were people who were single moms who lived in housing, and they couldn't get the landlock to fix a stove or something like that.
Part of, it was called an (federal) MA-4.
There were federal contracts that this company had.
And the goal, as I said, was to get people who were unemployable, employed, and to keep them employed.
So I worked there with that company for over 17 and a half years, but I moved from Washington to Minnesota, then back to Washington, and then to California, then to Minnesota.
And that's where I was before I came to Massachusetts.
Did you see any connections between that work and the Civil Rights Movement?
When you think about it, I think the Civil Rights was about helping people, helping people to get their rights, to be able to vote, to be able to spend their money where they wanted to be,
helping people to become good citizens where they can become viable, take care of themselves, own homes.
Yeah, I did.
And that's how I've seen my life.
I've been a mentor.
We were talking about my husband who's a trustee at his school.
We shared a lot, but I didn't share this.
I went with him a couple of times, and I would say to the lady at the receptionist, we were in a store, like a TJ Maxx.
She says, oh, she says, that's in Rochester or Buffalo.
I said, okay, and Rochester's like 60 miles, I took the keys, and I went to Rochester.
And I did it so like about three or four times, and then one time Fred would have things he had to do at night.
They'd be in meetings like from eight to five, they'd come home, five, thirty, they'd need to change your clothes, a bus was going to pick us up and take us to a reception or dinner right.
I slid in at six o'clock one night.
And Fred simply said to me, Jen, you're going to need to find something else to keep you losing.
And I said, okay, and I got the message.
So I sometimes I present training at the school.
I've done resume counseling with students, and I've also been a mentor.
And this is at Alfred University.
And I actually was appointed to the Leadership Advisory Board.
I was going to say you've got an award from them recently.
I was named in Honorary Alumni.
It was about two years ago, I think.
Two or three.
And did you, was part of that work with the Women's Center or something?
It was with the Women's Center.
So what happened was the Women's Center, Leadership Center, and then there was another part that was the Leadership Center.
One of the sponsors of the Women's Leadership Center died in a tragic accident.
And we renamed the Center, the Judson's Leadership Center, and they consolidated part of the Women's Program with the Leadership Program.
And I still am active with that.
In fact, we were talking, I have a meeting, a couple of weeks back there.
And that's where I, you know, I've been to the students.
And October, I'll be doing a training there as well.
Can you tell me what you enjoy about that?
Again, is that helping people in sharing.
Yeah.
I really, you know, I'd like being able to give back, you know, because I feel that so many people gave to me.
When I was that young person in that city where the sailors and everybody,
there are people who helped me to move on and to move out and supported me to go on to do what I've done so far.
And so that's what I really enjoy giving back, you know.
You said earlier when we were talking, maybe even on tape, that you haven't talked about being part of this city.
Never talked about it.
The first time that it came up was two years ago, I think it was, when they had the 50th anniversary and somebody started calling me saying you have to come, you should come and all about that.
And I sort of said, yeah, okay.
And all in finally, I think Fred said, Jen, you should go.
And his job was so that he could not go at the time, but he said, you should go.
And my niece lives in Richmond and my oldest nephew, they came to see me and they were really impressed.
And when I went, I was, I didn't realize the effect that we had had.
We were given credit. I couldn't believe it.
Credit for desegregating Richmond, Virginia.
The city?
I didn't know that.
Yeah.
Didn't I know that?
And I go to campus and here's a plaque and there's my name.
You know, I'm saying, oh my God, this is just from what we did that many years ago.
Had no idea, Emily.
So no idea.
Different idea.
Different perspective, but I still haven't shared it with a lot of people.
And I don't know why, maybe because I don't want to know people know I'm so old.
They've been subpoenaing me.
Let me get you in on a secret.
A lot of people can't do math.
That's good boy.
So you can tell them all.
I can tell them all.
You know, because I have a, like at one point, I was a child prodigy.
I was a child prodigy.
And at one point I thought about inviting some people to this and then I said, oh, I don't know.
I'm going to try to get through it myself.
And then I started thinking one time, well, what do I have to really say?
You know, I mean, we did it because we wanted to.
That's it.
Well, I know you said that you were interested in history, major dinner, and you're majoring in it.
Totted and continued to have an interest in it.
And, you know, I mean, I don't know.
Here you are.
You're somebody who's had an impact.
Everybody has some sort of impact on history, but yours is one that's a little bit more visible as part of the sit-in.
And my job doesn't know it.
Nobody at my work knows this.
So, do you think at all about sharing it or that it might be important?
I don't know.
You know, I go, you go back to that age thing.
Well, it's you somebody, oh, you were back then.
You went back to the dinner, right?
Back in the day.
So, I don't know.
And then, I don't know why.
It's just, you know, like washing your face, cleaning your teeth.
This is something that I did.
I was very young.
It was something very important to me.
Very meaningful for me.
I have no regrets.
And doing it.
But I'm not a person who brags.
Or talk about any accomplishments or anything.
I really talk about the accomplishment of my husband.
Yeah.
Well, I think has, you know, done a great job.
And it's a very, very brilliant man that I enjoy.
And my son, those are the things that I, you know, share.
And have them have the love.
I guess a little bit of self-filling me.
You know, it's interesting to hear you say that.
Because of course, I, you know, I teach.
Yeah.
And, um, and for my students, one of the things that seems to be most meaningful them for them is to talk to people who did something when they were the same age.
Yeah, probably.
And they say, oh, wow, then it makes me think I can do something.
You know, there's all these things going on in the world.
Sometimes they feel overwhelmed.
And so if you ever talk to the students at Alfred.
Maybe she or I think just to hear.
I might, I think now.
And so there's so many other things that I'm involved in.
And with students, the Springfield chapter of LINKS Incorporated, we have, we have young girls that we work, Susan that we work with to try to be, you know, someone to consider she rolls.
To these young girls who maybe not have others that maybe sometimes I might share.
And I might even share it with some of the members of my organization because what it tells us is that, you know, you can't have an impact, you know, and it's important to share your skills and your knowledge and everything that you've learned and acquired, you know.
Can you talk about that?
Well, it always is.
We're back.
Can you tell me a little bit about that organization and the work?
So this organization is called the LINKS Incorporated LINKS Incorporated. Incorporated.
It's a national women's organization made up predominantly of African American women.
It started in Philadelphia, about a hundred years ago, many years ago, because for social and friendship.
And now we have spread all out, we're international as well as national.
And we have six facets that we operate under, you know, its health and wellness, the arts, national trends and services, international trends and services.
I think I left one out youth, services to youth.
And so what our program center around those facets, and this group that I'm in is out of Springfield.
So what we've done is we've assessed the community of Springfield, which has a lot of needs.
And we've started to try to mentor young girls.
And some of them are parents that have no parenting skills, don't know how to interface with the schools.
We've also started to support a house that is called a village.
It's women who have been incarcerated and on drugs.
And so what we're doing, the organization is made up of people, such as myself, an executive counselor, trained executive counselor, human resources.
I know about jobs, searching and those things that we take our skills and we present workshops, counseling and tutoring and coaching these women to get successfully overcome their addictions, become better parents, get jobs, get their own homes.
And so we meet in Springfield in that surrounding area, monthly.
And we have projects that we work as well.
How far has Springfield from here?
About 50 miles, and the less than 50 miles.
And so are you seeing progress?
We've seen a lot of progress.
We've also supported some of the young girls who have...
So let me back up a number of the people in there, lawyers.
We have one young, one lady who's a very good friend of mine who's a superior court judge.
And we have a writer, we have different people.
And we've actually stuck with some of these young ladies and seen them graduate from high school, go on to college.
We keep in touch with some of them.
We also have an English, a blue sheet teaches English, a UMass Amherst, linguist, linguistics.
And she's actually sort of mentoring a young lady who graduated from high school and has gone on to UMass.
So she's there with her and sort of, you know, continuing to work with her.
So with Springfield, we've done some things in the city.
We've seen as much, it's just a lot of work that needs to be done there.
That must be rewarding.
It is, it is.
Is it hard to keep up with that and your work?
Well, you know, I actually, I've been involved in a lot of things.
And I began to scale back a little bit because so I lived here in Northborough, Massachusetts.
And I actually was a library trustee for a couple of years.
I was chaired to Community Affairs Committee,
which did things in the community to enhance the life of the citizens and everything like we did.
We do town clean-up.
We've done some of concerts in the park that tree, everything like that side chair.
That's like 15 years.
And I chair the personnel board for the town.
Well, two years ago, my husband decided that I should do something different.
And I said, okay.
And he says, there's a vacancy for the Assabet Valley Regional School District.
You should run.
I said, I'm not running Fred.
He said, oh, yeah, you should run.
It'd be something nice to do.
I said, I'm not running.
I got enough to do.
So he says, well, nobody signed up.
The date went by and everything like that.
So he says, well, you should do it right in.
You're Fred.
So Fred told a few people.
And I won, do it right in.
So now I'm a school committee member for regional school, vocational technical school.
And sometimes I wonder why.
So I did start in a writing.
I know he does.
He has a campaign.
So I have to get signatures when he's running.
So you have to have like 50 signatures.
So, but he likes to do more than 50 because suppose somebody isn't a registered voter or something like that.
So I help him to get signatures because he runs every year.
But so I did step down as a library trustee.
And I step down as the chair of the Community Affairs Committee.
So I still chair the personal board and the S.V.V. Valley.
And then I do my work with Alfred University.
And so I do a lot of mentoring.
I do a lot of miniature, an HR manager.
And I stay very busy with my job.
I used to, in addition to being a HR manager to hear the alternative dispute resolution,
which is an or was a process where if a person felt they were not being treated fairly or something like that,
they could come and present their case, be evaluated, and either have a reversal or it would remain the same.
So was that within the company or is that within the company?
Did that work well to avoid conflict or failure?
It does. It's very similar to, so if you're in a union, you have the five steps.
But it's a professional you don't.
So this is a way of working.
And it helps both the employee and the company.
But then it doesn't stop.
Sometimes people continue on to do lawsuits or MCAD, discrimination suits and everything like that.
So everything has sort of been along the same lines.
Mentoring, coaching, helping throughout my career.
And you mentioned your husband and his elections and his work.
So could you say just a little bit about that?
So there's some context for the, for other people.
Well, when I met my husband, he was a selectman.
And a selectman is in the state in Massachusetts, is like a city council.
And so he was a member of the city council.
And instead of having a chair, a mayor, you would, one of the members would chair.
So he's been a selectman.
He's chaired the board of selectman.
But prior to that, he was actually chair of the personal board.
And then he became, like I said, a selectman.
And then he's been a town moderator for 10 years.
The town moderator is, we have the old style government where you have town meetings.
And anybody who's a registered voter can come, be heard, listen to the budget, you know, questions and everything like that.
And his job is to facilitate that meeting and to keep it orderly, to get the budget passed or whatever needs to happen.
And it is all of any conflicts.
And all like that.
And plus, there's favorite thing I think is he appoints members to certain boards.
And so he's my boss.
He reminds me quite frequently. He's my boss.
So as a, as a personal board member, he appoints me.
But I was floored, Emily, when I had learned that he called the town administrator to see how, how had I done my job?
I can't believe it.
So how do you separate the work in coming home?
Very well.
I think we both, we both like and enjoy community work.
And like I was saying on a way coming over here, he was being very supportive and coming with me today.
But the third weekend of September, he will be so busy because he's the Applefest celebration.
And we have an Applefest celebration every year about the third weekend in September.
So we'll have a parade, we'll have fireworks, we'll have concerts and everything.
And he does all the announcing.
So are you keep busy?
So we both keep busy in town and we try to be supportive of each other.
And I can speak for him. I don't know, I let him speak for me, but I think it's extremely supportive for me.
I couldn't do it without him because it's nice.
He's also a human resources.
He has his own consulting practice.
And so he works with small and medium sized companies sort of consulting, human capital consulting and things like that.
And so we have the ability to share our work.
And sometimes if I want to just bounce something off of him, that I can, because I know I'll get a fair assessment and honest assessment.
Have you thought about running to be town moderator, so that you could be his boss?
Oh, no point in to afford him.
You have to know, you have to know Robert's Rules of Order.
You have to be patient.
And you have to speak very well.
And he has a very, I mean, sometimes we go on sometimes and somebody said, oh, you should be on radio.
You should be an announcer.
I'd just say.
But he's done that, been there.
And sometimes I think he thinks he should do voiceover or something.
But I don't have the patience, the knowledge or the ability.
I would probably, he stays what I admire.
Not a lot of things about him, but he doesn't show any favoritism or anything on his face.
I probably would be saying, you need to sit down and shut up.
That's sort of like when the lawyer walking back out.
You're exactly, exactly.
And you're riddled of five days, right?
You know, that's, I mean, one of the things I'm also interested in.
I was going to say one of the things I'm also interested in with the Civil Rights Room
and is non-violence and how it works.
And I think a lot of people have an image of the Civil Rights Room
and as just being completely non-violent and nobody ever had any urge for anything else.
No, no, no.
So a lot about anything else.
That's not true.
I mean, if you get spit, spit on, it's hard not to be angry or not to show some emotions.
Did you encounter any of that when you were marching to downtown that day?
Just the, people were yelling at us calling us names and everything.
And you just sort of had to just keep focused on your goal and don't make eye contact.
That's how we had to do it.
And so as we look at them, you actually give in to them and you're acknowledging them.
So you just keep, for you go on, don't look, don't respond or anything.
And did it help that you were doing that with your close friends?
Well, we got separated.
We were separated, right away.
I don't, I don't even remember.
I think I got arrested before them.
Yeah.
And, or, I'm not sure.
So when you went back to Richmond for this reunion and Virginia Union and found out that, you know,
people were saying you had this huge impact and stuff.
And what was it like to be back together with the students who had done that?
I wonder if I had not seen Marie (Sallasin) and Pat and Patricia Washington in years.
So the first thing, you know, we had an opportunity to catch up because Marie (Sallasin) and Pat had married a person who was in a military
and she had traveled all over and we'd lost contact with each other.
And Patricia Washington still lives in Philadelphia, outside of Philadelphia.
A newer husband had met them when they were dating so it was good to catch up.
Overwhelming to see what really people were saying.
They were calling us heroes.
So, okay, this (group of) 34, 34, desegregated the city of Richmond.
Yeah.
Did you know we did that?
Wow, that's wonderful.
Yeah.
To know, and I guess I was very proud that I had made the decision to participate and this was the result.
Do you think about the status of civil rights today?
I do.
Do you have any thoughts that you'd like to share on that?
You know, always have thoughts.
The first thought that I have, and this will come as a surprise to that I believe that racism is still rampant and apparent in the United States today.
I believe, I was well, I will say, I was so shocked when Obama was elected president.
I did not think that I would live to see an African-American president never in my Wallace dreams.
I thought that was something my son would experience.
However, although he was elected, I think it's racism that has been a part of the issues that he [Obama] has faced.
I mean, and that people would just get me so upset is that intelligent people don't see this and don't put a stop to it.
You know, there are so many senators and representatives that should never go back to Congress.
I mean, they sit and have lunch and say, hey, we're not going to agree or accept anything that he does.
How could you do that?
How could you not give this brilliant man an opportunity to be successful?
Racism is still alive.
And there are other things, but that's the one that just, you know, and there's something, and I think sometimes, you know, what can I do?
What should I do?
And like I said, to Fred sometimes, I think I should just quit and go work for, you know, try to work for Obama, do something to try, because it's not over.
We still have a lot to do.
But the good news is that our children don't see color today, you know.
And I have this conversation with my sister, who lives outside of Washington and the police call Looksville, and they're menaces, and where they chose to live, just as we're Fred and I have chosen to live.
There are very few African Americans.
So my sons, friends, are all white.
Does that mean?
And his cousins are the people of color that he knows closely and cares about and relates to.
But when we talked about having four and five kids at our house, the wrong way.
Does that create different kinds of challenges?
I don't think so. I think for them, it's easier.
You know, my son has never known about having to sit in the back of the bus.
My son doesn't, I think, well, I think he, in my opinion, and of course my husband may have a different opinion.
When he was in the seventh grade, I think it was, he came home and announced he wanted his hair braided.
I said, okay.
So we can't have routine every Sunday night.
We said that if something, he'd take his hair out and I'd braid it.
I think it was about the only African American in his class, and that was his way of showing that he was different.
And he wore his hair braided until he got to high school.
And now he wears a fume.
The only thing, the only time he could, the summertime, he'll cut it because it's hot.
But my man lets his hair, he used to play in a band too.
And he's like, I don't know if he's a big hair girl, it looks something like Lionel Richie.
This is the jazz, I don't have (Lionel) Lionel Richie.
But he looks like a, a Molly, Bob Marley, how Bob had the big hair.
My son has the big hair, you know, so he doesn't hide his ethnicity.
He cuts it, you can't tell.
Sometimes I have friends in California who say if he's coming out there, please have him shave and everything
because he may take him part of a Muslim or some Islam that goes shot or whatever.
Does he see the existence of racism still?
I don't think so.
No, he never sees things in terms of color, which is good.
So, I mean if something happens to, in our day, if something happened to you, you didn't get promoted
or you didn't do something, it was because of your race, he doesn't see that.
You may see partiality.
But he doesn't see race.
Well, can you think of things that are important, things that you think people should think about or know about?
Things I haven't thought to ask you.
Oh, I'm thinking.
I don't know.
That's a big question.
I'm just trying to think about it.
I guess for me, just thinking about me, I think that I've always had the civil rights fight in my blood.
On my job and my life, I will fight for what I think is right.
If something is happening a lot of times in my work, people come to me and they ask me for help.
And I will give them that help.
And it's off the record kind of thing, but it's more or less like, you know, they're dealing with, and I see racism.
I see it, you know.
And I've been trying to figure out how do you get others to see the racism that exists because it's so subtle.
For example, if you hire, you can hire a person of color or a female, but you may not give them the total job or the job that they can be most successful in.
And, or you can finally maybe hire a person of color who's very, very good and you won't let them move.
They keep them right in that position because you don't want to lose them.
But you lose them anyway because they go to another company.
So what I've been trying to, I'll just give you some.
Lately, our company seems to be changing the way they do business.
We'll have the old type HR.
So they have business partners.
And so you're made, you end up with a lot of different projects, you know, salary planning, HR review, things like that.
But they don't look back at the basics.
And I had, I just, I had a couple of experiences that someone came to me that someone was complaining that someone went in the ladies room and a person said,
I think you have the wrong bathroom.
And so nobody thought anything of it, right?
And then I had somebody else to say, you know, there's someone visiting and we think that person is going through a chain.
So I'm working on transgender issues at my company and I'm this close to getting gender neutral bathroom,
at least two general neutral bathrooms near the manufacturing floor because I work for a manufacturing company.
There's like over 4,000 people, lots of square footage.
But there is no gender neutral bathroom so that if I'm transitioning, I have some place I can comfortably go.
Or if I'm just sick and I want to go someplace like that.
So I started that and then I had a situation where someone came to me and needed help.
And my role, that's my role, and trying to understand and trying to help that person that I'm actually helping to rewrite or put together training that talk to management and leaders about sensitive issues like this.
We've had it before, but in one situation, I mean an employee says to someone, when did you know your realizement?
Or when did you know you were out with your back surgery instead of, you know, you out back surgery, did you transition?
It's like the inappropriate conversations and questions.
So I'm working with some people to try to train people to make things better because it's still, we got a long way to go.
So do you find resistance to that or is it just more like just kind of lethargy or no?
I think people just don't know.
Some people just don't know and they just don't understand.
But then there are some people who are going through things and they don't know how to deal.
The recent situation I had is where a person, it was one of the female, but feels that he is a male.
But he's taken no steps.
So people don't understand and he, I think, hasn't really gotten his mind wrapped around that.
And so people, he feels people discriminate on harass him.
But harassing, saying, did you have a sex change, isn't really harassing. That's an appropriate.
So training people, not to ask personal and appropriate questions.
So I mean, so yeah. So it goes from one thing to another.
But it's all related. It's all related.
And it's about understanding differences, valuing the differences, and letting people have their own ability to make their choices and to live their choices.
So I'm trying to think now, what's my next step?
You know, am I going to teach? Am I just going to sit home and read like one of my girlfriends?
Or I don't see that.
I see so many shaking hands behind you.
But I'm thinking about transitioning myself to figure out maybe more community work and not sure.
So you think you might want different challenges coming up in the future.
I'm really proud of myself if I get those two bathrooms at that company.
I had some waiting, you know, it's budget. I got support.
It's now getting the budget to do that.
So you've been able to convince people it's a good thing. It's just a question of actually now implementing.
Right.
Right. And then next step is completing a training where I'll help the trained managers.
What do you do? How do you do? And, you know, just coach.
Yeah. So it sounds like some major accomplishments for me.
Yeah. Yeah.
So can you think of any final thoughts or we can take a second and think about it too?
No. I think I just about, I'm shared just about everything that I can.
Well, we really appreciate it.
And we're very pleased to have your story as part of the Civil Rights History Project.
I hope it's helpful. It is. Thank you.
Thank you. Thank you.
It has been a presentation of the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.